well Chris Baker one thing is for sure
III is back i mean look look around you
look at all these people look at all
these boots look at all these booth
babes there's got to be some here
somewhere I don't know the big trend at
e3 this year very very clear its camera
controllers its motion controllers
Nintendo had a huge success with the wii
and now Sony and Microsoft want to make
it known that they too are working on
controllers that are about you jumping
around like an idiot yeah and I'd say on
a related note what these new
controllers mean is what they're trying
to do here is not launch your new
console but sort of reinvent their
consoles with a completely new play
control you know no one wants to shell
out money for a new console right now
but this is their chance to kind of make
it fresh so I think that's what Sony and
Microsoft are focusing on it's true
Chris Baker you know this is the time
generally in the life cycle of the video
game consoles where companies would
start announcing new consoles you know
not releasing them but announcing them
at e3 and the fact that nobody is
talking about new consoles at all it
really is true they're trying to
revitalize their old consoles with new
games new controllers new ways to play
not making people buy something brand
new Microsoft had project natal a
controller that you there is no
controller it's a camera and you just
use your body to control games Sony had
something that's sort of a cross between
the wiimote and camera controllers you
hold the controller and the camera
tracks the controller and it can
superimpose really cool stuff you know
on to the controller itself so it looks
like you're holding a sword and finally
Nintendo said hey you know we've got wii
motionplus sony's got this controller
that's coming out next year Microsoft's
gotta control is coming out next year
we've got wii motionplus that's out next
week so actually if you know you want to
get true one to one motion control by
wii sports resort in july
I guess let's go ahead and talk about
how would we rate the press conferences
well who would you say had the best one
honestly I feel like they all had
equally good press conferences Sony's
was a lot more like you know kind of
they they showed a lot more game
trailers and things like that it was
more exciting but in terms of the number
of announcements I thought that
everybody had a couple of big good new
announcements you know Microsoft had the
camera sony had the Last Guardian by the
Eco team and sony also had final fantasy
14 online exclusive Nintendo was no
slouch either I mean besides you know
New Super Mario Brothers and games like
that they also announced the brand new
metroid game that's going to be made in
collaboration between Nintendo and the
Ninja Gaiden team so I think that
everybody had a pretty big announcements
whoa what do you think I'd say so as
well I'm hearing a lot of grumbling that
if you fall outside of Nintendo's target
demographic they didn't have much to
offer they actually the only the only
new controller they demoed was a
heartbeat sensor and we're literally
thinking aloud about the possibility of
games that don't excite you but calm you
down and put you to sleep video games
have been developed to give an increased
sense of excitement was stimulation but
it may not be long before games are also
used to let people online what even make
it easier to fall asleep and that was
maybe a little too on the nose but I've
heard some grumbling about that I was
very excited about some of the demos I
saw there I guess Sony had the most
people in the audience whooping and
hollering which is kind of what I
associate with a classic p3 press
conference well Sony invited a lot of
PlayStation fans to come and sit in the
press conference so they know they yeah
you know they made that happen they know
what they're doing for better for worse
III is bad